we've had details from Buckingham Palace
about the coronation and guidance as to
the size we do know that it is going to
be considerably smaller than the last
coronation which was of course in 1953
and it's going to look very different to
the Queen's coronation it will be
televised but the service is likely to
be an hour rather than the three hours
of the Queen's coronation and the number
of people invited well there were 8 000
VIPs and dignitaries invited to the
Queen's coronation we're understanding
closer to 2000 we'll be invited to
Charles's coronation to give you an idea
that's about the number of people that
were invited to the Queen's funeral so
it's not a case that the Abbey is going
to look empty by any means and in terms
of Pomp and pageantry what are we going
to see lots of concerns over here in the
UK that that might also be scaled back
well my sources assure me that there
will be plenty of spectacle comp and all
the pageantry you would expect for a
ceremony that is really nearly 1000
years old and we're expecting to see the
king and the queen consort taken to
Buckingham Palace in the gold State
coach as well that would be quite
respectful that most of us have never
seen before the early days of King
Charles's Reign are being closely
scrutinized the King has traveled around
the United Kingdom and it all seems to
be very well received certainly over
here in the UK but of course there is
still that issue of the familial Rift
that ruption at the heart of the House
of Windsor and a lot of people are
wondering whether Harry Megan and their
children will be coming over for the
coronation whether that will finally
signal some thawing of the rift that
people had hoped might have taken place
over the Queen's funeral but sadly
didn't really ever get to that point so
what can we expect to see of the whales
and their children well we we know that
Prince William is going to have a pretty
high profile and significant role not
just in the ceremony itself but the lead
up to the coronation along with the
Princess of Wales and I think we can
absolutely expect to see Prince George
and Princess Charlotte who behaved so
impeccably on the day of the Queen's
funeral who've shown that they are
absolutely able to behave according to a
situation even one as formal as this and
don't forget this is all part of the
training for Prince George who will one
day be king and who will like Prince
Charles when he was that much younger
just four watched his mother crowned
this will be Prince George watching his
grandfather crown with his father
looking onto knowing that he will be
next
[Music]
foreign